the reason why I do this I want to
experiment you need to experience it I
want to experiment it you think this is
a cheating you think I'm Che no this not
cheating this is not
cheating Joy takes asell to the strip
club for the first time and he falls in
love I don't get why Joie would
introduce this world to his friend who
is already having issues with temptation
I swellow is is a Serial cheater and
you're introducing him to a strip club
that's like introducing someone who you
know has an addiction problem to a New
Drug while they're in rehab they are in
coup's therapy for goodness sake all
right all right all right that's enough
I swear we got to get you out of here
let's go I don't want him to get in
trouble ladies I'm so sorry and yeah
things go a little too far I did my best
and focus on my marriage meanwhile
Kanani is sharing more details about her
night with the fall pass guy Dallas
having slept with Dallas kind of opened
my eyes to a different world a whole
world yep there's no turning back now
let's get into
it hey 90day fans famam it's melissia
woo this last resort episode was juicy a
lot went down I unblocked the other guy
and then he texted me to come see
him and I spent the night
there it's a few days before the couples
have their commitment ceremony to decide
if they want to be together or not
meanwhile Kanani just revealed that her
Hall Pass guy Dallas flew out to see and
profess his love to her while she's at a
Couple's Retreat with her husband that's
a bold move Kanani Kanani Kanani as much
as I love you you can't have the here
when you're at a therapy trying to save
your marriage girl it's going to be a
disaster but I will say I kind of get it
if Michael was treating me like
that what fan all over that beach Wait
what did she
say fan all over that beach that's that
gangster side of Angela
Talking fan all over that beach we're
going to see her Memo side come out in a
few which I love all right back to
colani in Dallas so I went to go see him
with good intentions I was just going to
talk to him and see how things were and
like try to figure out what we were
doing Angela asked keani the golden
question why would she do that if she's
trying to work on her marriage that's
when she reveals to Angela and Yara what
she already told Liz he's cheated on me
the whole
time but the biggest thing is so he
cheated so he cheated more than once oh
he's cheated like 12 times
oh I would have done cut his penis off
that was a very Angela response and O
Karma can be a you know what as swellow
committed all of this infidelity
throughout the years and Kanani kept it
a secret to protect him I wanted him to
get along with my dad and with my family
members so I just kept it hidden and now
in front of the world his behavior is
not only being EXP exposed but we're
watching him lose his wife to another
man the world is watching his wife cheat
on
him so what are you going to do now only
a couple days left before the commitment
ceremony are you going to the r to the
ceremony yeah I don't
know that scare you oh yeah to tell him
like oh yeah we've been together almost
seven years and I don't want to be with
you anymore yeah but it's a result of
his actions I can already see a huge
lesson Kanani can take away from her
entire relationship with ASU is to not
sacrifice herself and her peace for a
man's comfortability as if his
comfortability is more important than
hers now I know she's a mommy and from
what I've heard and seen you can get
used to putting yourself on the back
burner but no it's time for Kanani to
prioritize herself she's not responsible
for asu's action
and she would be doing him a disservice
if she keeps trying to save him from the
lessons he clearly needs to learn
betraying your wife's trust 10 to 12
times no some things not clicking buddy
that needs to
click hey you see what's going on here
look at this this crazy as girl chat is
going on Joy Big Ed and aello are headed
out to blow off some steam and I must
say this is a very weird group dynamic
you guys I may just fall asleep yeah I
don't blame you actually got a lot of
sleep last night for the first time in a
while oh that's good that you guys have
a nice sleep is everything okay no it's
there's a lot that thinking about
there's a lot going on
yeah I feel really sad today Kalan
eventually texts me this morning and
tells me she's okay and I don't even
know where she's at last night or this
morning I love her very much I try so
hard to make this marriage work out I
was it you but I feel really tired yeah
that feeling of being tired is heavy but
it can actually be a good place to be in
because that's when you start to
surrender you let go and you let
whatever is going to be be I did my best
and focus on my marriage but having
slept with Dallas
yep she got some last night having slept
with Dallas kind of opened my eyes to a
different world there's effort there
that there's never been with ellu I'm
happy that Kanani is realizing what is
possible in a
relationship but my hope is that she
takes it slow she's only known this
Dallas guy for 2 months and there are
people out there who like to love bomb
do all these wonderful things to get you
and and then they stop not saying that's
Dallas but as she reemerges into the
dating world after being wiped up for so
long it's something to be aware of I
think what's kept me with u so long is
keeping my family unit together but I
think by doing that I'm always just
torturing myself I just feel like I'm
I'm just going to lose something no
matter what I
pick
and when you've put as much time and
energy and everything into a
relationship like I have it's
just
sucks the emotions literally have Kanani
sick to her
stomach I feel like I'm going to throw
up I swallow was talking about he's
tired which I believe but imagine how
Kanani is feeling she's worn out
exhausted and she's throwing up the body
talks girl
listen
a Here Comes M my Angela to give her a
hug I love when Angela is in her
grandmommy mode sorry come here come
here come here not what I
want I didn't want
this you didn't do this this is this is
the consequences he has to face and it
shouldn't be your guilt Kar should have
left a long time ago I felt her pain I
see it I feel it you know she lasts one
minute and then she's crying the next
but at the end of the day I think she
needs to make a decision for her not for
everybody else yes as Kanani is
processing her emotions aello is with
the guys trying to distract himself from
his baby aello JY and Big Ed arrive at a
bar and make plans for the rest of the
night what do you you drinking it's the
Sprite with the Cherry that's called a
surely Temple and when I do how would
you like to be my crew and by the way I
will say I commend asu's choice in this
moment to not drink his feelings
away it's no use it doesn't work why you
not drinking real alcohol and that was
such a JY
response I'm going through a lot
in the morning uh because we're not
sleeping together at the same room so
today I text her good morning my
beautiful you want me to bring your same
breakfast and she was like she's not
here I think she's sleeping somewhere
out she hooked up with somebody I mean I
asked her right like I asked her where
yeah and she like I don't know where I
am and try FaceTime and she didn't
answer so I try again she didn't answer
do you not know where you are like this
is not
okay a i s looks like he's about to cry
Big Ed then tells him the hard truth I
know that it sucks but I just want you
to start preparing yourself for for both
scenarios for both scenarios if I were
in his shoes I would probably try to cut
my losses and move on we're all trying
to get through therapy in one piece and
you know we wanted to come out we wanted
to have a fun night you're right we're
supposed to be out having a good time so
cheers cheers to Charle temples maybe
we'll have him get a real drink I'm
trying to have fun you know what I'm
saying how can I support you somebody
has been listening in therapy talking
about how can I support you that's good
to the
stripper so the talk about going to the
strip club has been discussed amongst
the guys for a few episodes now but they
were hesitant to tell Ed because he
can't keep a secret and he proves their
point when he admits to JY and ASU that
he told Liz about their plan so I know I
pinky
sweared that I wouldn't tell Liz we're
going to a strip
club but I
did I knew that Ed couldn't keep a
secret and he continues to be
himself and next week it looks like Ed
is going to piss Joy off even
more yeah
but bringing it back Joy comes up with
this elaborate plan so they can go to
the strip club with no issues at least
that's what he thought maybe Liz has
been drinking with the girls and if you
call her and say Hey look it's me joy
ASU ASU is having a hard day he wants to
go to the strip club can I go with him
oh he's good Big Ed calls Liz and I
guess Joy didn't think that the phone
might be on speaker phone or Liz might
tell Yara but he sets himself up for a
problem with his wife we have a question
will you give Ed permission to come to
the strip club with us
[Applause]
tonight he wants to be nice and get your
permission before he goes without you
telling
me don't tell uhuh see that's your
problem right now ASU and don't tell the
girls dang Kanani doesn't even seem
bothered and when it comes to Yara I can
only imagine how tired she is of Joy's
obsession with the strip club from the
outside looking in it's so hard to
understand he has a beautiful wife at
home but you know what I think if Joy
had the most perfect woman in the world
whatever that is he would still enjoy
going to the strip club I'm not going to
hold anything against you yeah Liz tells
Ed he can go so seemingly without even
thinking about how would feel Joy
prepares to take asell to the strip club
for the first time so I'm going to text
these strippers I'm going to strip
upub maybe it's Ed's first time
too he's a little too excited let's do
it what she said I don't know I'm
messing her now y'all chill out joy said
Relax hello
ladies right yall ready
what's up
man I swell was feeling himself and once
they sit down in the club he becomes
mesmerized by the
[Music]
strippers entering the strip clubs and
see those girls dancing the ball I only
watched that in the movies and hearing
from Joy's mouth but now see them in my
my real eyes this is very very wild
first time looking those things wow I
want to touch it well there's definitely
some close
contact oh my God the SW I think she
likes you very close oh SW is funny like
it's really funny to watch him
interacting yeah give her all the money
watching him try to throw the money
looking at the girl just kind of like a
little bit in
shock how you climb up there love how
he's got his money in a hat oh my God TR
you're learning he's learning fast he's
learning
fast he kiss it do do kiss it a swell
that's what got you in trouble the last
time your tongue turned white you didn't
learn your
lesson do it do it do it do it do it y
there we go JY looks like he is having a
time and he opens up about when his love
for the strip club first started going
to strip clubs has been kind of a
constant I would say throughout my life
first time ever to a strip club when I
was 16 I used to climb in on Bourbon
Street they had a little gate right and
I would like squeeze through the gate
and I would run up the stairs before
security could find me and then I would
just sneak into the club yeah it's quite
a few nights like that I wonder have
they done a dive into his obsession with
the strip club and therapy I would love
to be a fly on the wall for that
conversation all right aso's night at
the strip club ends with him getting his
first lat dance I feel really scared
because you know I don't have a lot
dance before and I don't know what they
going to do hopefully it's going to be
nice
Gucci boy you think this is a cheating
you think I'm this is not cheating this
is not cheating this definitely looks
like a form of cheating to me I swear
this is the best first lap dance anyone
can possibly get ever oh get it out
swu what oh my God this his first time
sitting in the chair and with three
beautiful ladies on top of me man I feel
like I'm in heaven but I'm a Christian
so I feel like this is
hell what did Joy
do the lab dance ends up going a little
too far we got to get out of here who SW
and joy steps in yes having been to
enough strip clubs I definitely know
when it's time to go all right all right
all right that's enough ASU we got to
get you out of here let's go I don't
want him to get in trouble ladies I'm so
sorry ASU walks out of the door giving
the place a festar review excellent
torturous I really love strip clubs I
wish I can bring this to some more man
I'll be a millionaire
amazing well at least he enjoyed himself
that night Joy too because he got it
from Yara when he returned to the resort
you want to know who's the only guy who
didn't touch a stripper in that whole
place who me no snitching huh if you
would have seen a swellow and head and
what they were doing in the strip club
you understand like I'm a angel you
telling that that you are innocent right
now but that was your day for they go
over there you just obsessed with your
stupid streepers all the time and I God
why would you not like I I you have a
beautiful wife beautiful why would you
do that to me don't Don't ugly or
something and why would you lie to me
why stop it no talk no no
no no talk to me right this is
disgusting talk to me right
now with this it's too
early
Joy has a crazy obsession with Street
buub crazy obsession with alcohol and I
think I will I am kind of looking nice
to give him stuff but he doesn't go over
there but he's still obsessed with that
and he lies to me when it comes to J's
quote obsession with alcohol I asked him
how he felt after Yara threatened to
divorce him a few episodes ago after he
and Angela woke her up in the middle of
the night after a little too much to
drink if you going to do this to me
you'll be going to get divorced has
watching yourself back made you
re-evaluate your relationship with
alcohol at all oh my God I hate it I
hate to look back at that moment but to
be honest that night I was just stressed
out I had a little bit too much to drink
and hopefully that doesn't happen again
yeah I was feeling the moment when I say
that I was really feeling because for me
it was hurtful and when it comes to ASU
it looks like things are going to get
even more painful for him next episode
as he's back to facing reality well
Kanani's called this this meeting
honestly I feel really scared to tell
Oso the truth I'm just terrified of how
he's going to react the other guy asked
if I would meet him to talk about things
and I
went we ended up doing other
things
she that's
tough y'all we got to be careful how we
treat people out here because clearly
Karma does not play games and I'm not
one to usually throw that saying around
but it's so obvious
here all right 90day fans famam make
sure you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next
[Music]
time